until his demise over his tax Affairs
Nadeem zahawi's career was a classic
rags to Rich's story from Child Refugee
who spoke no English to
multi-millionaire businessman and Senior
cabinet minister
but his wealth has proved to be his
undoing
[Music]
born in 1967 and Mr zahawi and his
family fled Saddam Hussein's regime in
Iraq
well I think this country has given me
everything I have lived the British
dream I came here at the age of 11
couldn't speak a word of English hid at
the back of the class okay and of course
Very quickly learned to read and speak
the language but actually think in the
like dream in the language and I want to
deliver the opportunity for every uh
child in our country every family
in 2000 he founded the polling company
yougov with the help of his father and
it was his father's shares that landed
him in the tax dispute that has cost him
his job
thank you Mr Speaker elected MP for
Stratford on even in 2010 as the UK's
first Kurdish Iraqi MP Mr zahari soon
made his Mark in the Commons and cut
through the bureaucracy and nonsense and
fly the flag of England over towning
Street for the duration of the World Cup
but for the maid debate today
historically they have been vexed about
how to pay but he hit the wrong note a
year later when his musical tie went off
during his own speech
I apologize
um it is as a junior minister in 2018 Mr
zahari survived controversy over
attending a men only president's Club
dinner could you give us a comment on
why you attended for dinner well Hostess
has suffered sexual harassment young
ladies hostesses
um that came around each table which
made me feel incredibly uncomfortable
which is why I
left the uh dinner
but it was as vaccines Minister during
the covid pandemic that Mr zahawi made
his name and welcome to Downey Street
for today's coronavirus briefing and
emerged as a Tory rising star and today
I can confirm we've reached the
Milestone of three in five
three in five all adults getting the
protection
of a second dose
his impressive media performances earned
him promotion to Boris Johnson's cabinet
as education secretary
then when Rishi sunak abruptly quit as
Chancellor in July last year he was
handed the treasury but only two days
after his appointment he called for Mr
Johnson to resign
by Mr Johnson quit Mr zahawi stood for
the Tory leadership good evening
Birmingham what a great privilege it is
uh for me to be here tonight on home
tough two candidates will be eliminated
Jeremy Hunt and Nadeem zahal but he
dropped out early along with Jeremy Hunt
who's now Chancellor
it was during that contest that
questions were first raised about Mr
zahawi's Tax Affairs but he came out
fighting clearly being smeared I was
being told that that the serious thought
offers that the National Crime is the
hmrc are looking uh into me I've yeah
I'm not aware uh of this I will I've
always declared my taxes I paid my taxes
in the UK uh I was you know answer any
questions hmrc has uh uh of me have you
been honest about your tax Affairs Mr
zahawi but after spells as cabinet
office Minister under Liz truss and Tory
chairman under Mr sunac he now says he
made a careless and not deliberate error
in his tax affairs
I think the significance is that he had
a lot of tax that he should have paid
and he didn't pay it
he's never explained why and instead of
explaining
he resorts to lawyers he resorts to
denials while secretly behind the scenes
sending accountants to negotiate a deal
with hmrc that's not something a senior
politician should be doing
Mr zahawi has paid the price for what
labor has called a murky Affair but a
politician who began his life under the
tyranny of Saddam Hussein will regard
his demise as a setback and not the end
of his political career
John Craig Sky News